I'm joined today by Malcolm lecompt
who's a retired associate professor at
Elizabeth City State University and
currently research co-director at the
comment Research Group we're going to be
talking today really about a few
different things Malcolm but I think the
best place to start is what is known as
the Younger Dryas impact hypothesis
which relates to sort of the not
incredibly distant past of Homo sapiens
but at least when it comes to known
history certainly on the reaches of what
we know let's start with the controversy
just to get people up to speed who may
not even know what it is we're talking
about what do we mean when we say the
Younger Dryas impact hypothesis well
there's a number of events that occurred
only called the Holocene or the
Pleistocene Holocene transition that's a
period of at the end of the Ice Age the
last ice age about 18,000 years ago
there was a period of warming that had
some some intervals of cooling and
warming again but the general trend was
warming and at about 13,000 years ago
there was actually more solar insolation
there is today and the earth appeared to
be coming out of the Ice Age fairly
rapidly at about this time the it
suddenly went back into a very very cold
snap the megafauna which had been
currently on the road to extinction or
at least diminishing in numbers seems
taken abrupt nosedive in numbers and
there's also some evidence although
disputed that there was some sort of
reorganization of the North American
Clovis culture at the time we've got
some quarries that appeared to a bit
abandoned and for a long time it was
either attributed to some of these these
events were attributed to climatic
conditions a pandemic of some sort or
just the climate itself going back into
the deep freeze it was almost as bad for
about a thousand 1215 hundred years as
it was during the height of the icy it's
not quite but but close and during that
period
these events seem to have accelerated or
or or begun right at the start of that
period and it's been a mystery as to
exactly to what what what circumstances
prompted those events to occur whether
they were related or not is another
question and so Malcolm did it just to
summarize what you've said so far in
total layman's terms for our audience
the the idea is that about 13,000 years
ago there was a decline in both
megafauna large animals on the planet as
well as the the human population and the
cause of that decline is sort of what
what is the the center of this
discussion or controversy and one
possibility was that it was some kind of
climactic climactic event or climactic
characteristics and then an alternative
proposal to that is the what you've been
working on am I sort of up to speed as
far as what we've said so far I think
it's pretty accurate that I think
basically subsumes all of all those
factors or circumstances and the the
most I guess the original proposal of an
extraterrestrial impact to comment or an
asteroid impact was we've seen as as a
kind of a quick fix to explain all those
those particular events I think it's
probably the truth probably more
complicated than that but but that was
sort of the original driving assumption
so this has actually become quite a
controversy some some of my audience if
you also watch the Joe Rogan podcast
there was about a three-hour discussion
involving a number of people graham
hancock and michael shermer and it was
really quite a whole thing that I that I
obviously know you're intimately
familiar with Malcolm and this has
become really quite a controversy within
within some elements of the science
community why is this so controversial
in other words what would be the
implications of this hypothesis on our
understanding of human history well it's
got a number of um
of what consequences or if if it says
this pans out which it looks like right
now that it is it's got a number of
consequences or at least points to a
number of directions that in some cases
Gore people's oxes favorite favorite
hypotheses or theories about what
actually happened then and and in the
course of our history and we're kind of
beyond history here this is I would say
a good ol seven or eight thousand years
before what would consider history in
the classical realm eastern
Mediterranean and another historic site
so this is well before history but it's
in the I guess you'd consider kind of
the middle Neolithic I'm not an
archaeologist so I'm sort of reaching
for terms here that seem to to to be
descriptive so thirteen thousand years
ago we have this this evolving culture
and then this climate event and and
there have been circle II people of
state the reputations or careers on
explaining certain elements of these of
these these events like the decline of
the megafauna the eventual extinction
the climate event that occurred and the
possibility of a organizational change
in the Clovis culture which is a culture
that inhabited North America and there's
a number of there's a number of
controversies that attend this whether
Clovis was the first North American
culture or not where they came from so
there's a lot of a lot of things tied up
into this and then there's also the sort
of the astronomical or geophysical
problem of just how do how often do
these events occur and the idea that
there was this significant event if it's
proven out to be as significant as as it
appears to be in the initial early so
many early returns how wide the extent
of this this event was felt then you've
got a condition where you've got more
impacts more significant impacts than
perhaps
participated in the models that were
using today for predicting how often
these things occur in other words if
there was such a great impact 13,000
years ago that would change how likely
we should consider a future impact to be
well it may change the models themselves
because this event doesn't seem to it
doesn't look like the KT event in terms
of what you find and and and how
devastating so I guess the conclusion
would be that if this thing had the
effects we think it had or at least it
appears to have had then it means that
smaller impacts can be far more deadly
and devastating than we had previously
surmised
and that that these small impacts are
far more likely to happen than the big
KT kinds of impacts of the KT is the
dinosaur killer and there are others
other impacts that were sort of like
looking called minor extinction events
but but have occurred through the past
that are more class mated big craters
big smoking holes and and they do a lot
of damage to the earth this thing
doesn't appear to have done that we
don't quite know why so as a
non-scientist
I couldn't possibly touch every single
aspect of this conversation but there
are at least a few questions that I'm
curious how you might answer with regard
to the idea of this major impact from a
comet or asteroid one is with regard to
the extinction of the megafauna right
these big animals and I read a number of
peer-reviewed scientific studies whose
names would not be a particular element
to our audience but we can obviously put
put out the the studies of people are
interested that showed that the
extinction timings of these megafauna
were not all simultaneous in other words
that they took really some anywhere from
hundreds to even a thousand years to
happen how would an acute event like a
comet or asteroid hitting the planet
lead to extinctions over such a long
period of time in other words wouldn't
the extinctions happen much more closely
to each other if it was the result of
such an event uh yeah if it was all
attributed to that yes it looked like I
mean from what I've seen the the
megafauna were sort of on their way out
when this thing occurred and I don't
know why that was babe
that apparently and maybe the the influx
of humans into the into the area
undoubtedly had some effect just how big
an effect it was is is a obviously being
debated
an impact of this sort where as fairly
significant could change the ecosystem
in fact it's it's fairly well known and
well developed theory that that an
impact a large impact can collapse the
ecosystem that has major effects as well
as just killing the animals outright
that you're looking for much broader and
more global aspects of this and it's
we're recognizing now that that the
effects of this impact were spread over
a very very wide area so in other words
it's possible that if there was an
impact the impact might have immediately
driven some species to extinction and
then the subsequent extinctions were as
a result of the impact of the first
extinctions on the food chain for
example or on the environment is that
roughly the idea yeah I don't think the
I suspect that the number of animals
killed outright is probably relatively
small compared to the numbers that
suffered after-effects and if you've got
a population of humans that are suddenly
faced with starvation they're going to
be hunting these animals as as soon as
their diet
if the ecosystem is collapsed the diet
is going to be suddenly limited to the
animals that are still around they're
going to be hunting very aggressively
hmm
another one I came across Malcolm is
that there's there's a paper called
impact hypothesis and North American
paleo-indians by holliday and Meltzer
and it takes issue with the younger
younger drives impact hypothesis by
saying that the paleo-indian population
decline that some believe happened and
is sort of part of the evidence
supporting the hypothesis is not
actually something that we can
definitively say happened I mean is that
what kind of a disagreement is that it
seems like a sort of fundamental
disagreement on the facts well I see I
think we have some very fundamental
difference with with both Meltzer and
Holliday and you know
I think it's it's it's becoming more
evident that the impact is is becoming
harder and harder to dispute because the
evidence keeps piling up on the other
hand whether or not how big was the
impact on the Clovis culture is is uh is
it other matter to me that the first
order of business is to prove the impact
and that's not easy under any
circumstances so that's that's sort of
where I'm at is just trying to prove the
impact and collect the evidence to see
how broad the impact effects were and
and establish that and then I think a
second-order question is how did it
affect the environment the megafauna
in the human population we've got some
evidence that there was distinct and
we've got a number of archaeologists who
were quite quite well respected and well
known that are very much in the camp of
saying that this impact explains a great
deal of what they've seen and these are
good field archaeologists as well so I
would say that it's it's not a one-sided
dispute between archaeology and the on
the geophysical science of of the impact
study it's sort of a two camps of
archaeologists that are in opposition
and then you've got the physical
scientists or sort of developing the the
evidence or disputing the evidence on
one side of the other so the hell do we
like what's going on we could talk about
it for hours but unfortunately we don't
have that much time but I hope the
audience will become at least interested
enough to research more about this it's
very very interesting and quite quite a
controversy that that has been
developing over the last five to ten
years Malcolm lecompt current research
co-director at the comet research group
thanks for talking to us about this
today my pleasure